السعال وفحص الازدحام
تحقق من الحمى تحقق من وجود قائمة
بالأعراض ولكن في وقت الحساسية ،
الأنفلونزا وفيروس كورونا
كيف تعرف ما الذي يجعلك مريضًا
عندما يتعلق الأمر بأعراض الحساسية تميل الأعراض
إلى البقاء في رأسك
هل تعاني من سيلان الأنف وحكة
العطس في العين ، وربما حتى
الصداع ، إذا كنت تعاني من
الحساسية الموسمية ، خاصة إذا كنت
تميل إلى الشعور بهذه الأعراض
في نفس الوقت تقريبًا من كل عام ، إذا
لم يكن سببًا لك هو نزلة برد مع الأنفلونزا ،
ابحث عن الحمى  التعب
وآلام الجسم والسعال عادة ما
يقترن بالتهاب الحلق
بينما عادة ما تحل أعراض البرد والإنفلونزا الخفيفة
نفسها
مع الأنفلونزا الشديدة والفيروس التاجي ، وقد
تزداد سوءًا
قبل أن تتحسن عندما يتعلق
الأمر بفيروس كورونا ، فإن مراكز
السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها تريد منك ذلك
ابحث عن بعض الأعراض الرئيسية
مثل الحمى أو السعال الجاف أو ضيق التنفس
أو عدم القدرة على التنفس بعمق
أيضًا إذا كنت قد تعرضت
لشخص لديه
يعتقد خبراء الفيروسات أن العديد من الأشخاص الذين يصابون بفيروس
كورونا سوف يعانون من
أعراض خفيفة أو لا يعانون من أي أعراض على الإطلاق إذا كنت
تواجه صعوبة في التنفس أو
ألم في الصدر مستمر أو غير معتاد
أو ارتباك يشير القرص المضغوط إلى أن هذه قد
تكون علامات تحذير طارئة لفيروس
كورونا وتسعى للحصول على رعاية طبية طارئة من
أجل  دقيقة الصحة اليوم ، أنا ميريديث
وود ،
الشوارع الفارغة ، المواقع الجانبية التجارية المغلقة ،
لن
ينسى الأمريكيون قريبًا ، وتشير دراسة جديدة إلى
أننا إذا لم نقم
بكل ما فعلناه للبقاء في المنزل لإغلاق
المدارس التي تقيد السفر
والبقاء بعيدًا اجتماعيًا عن
بداية الوباء  خلال
أوائل أبريل ، سيكون هناك حوالي 60
مليون إصابة أخرى بفيروس كورونا في
جميع أنحاء
البلاد ، استخدم البحث المنشور في مجلة الطبيعة العلمية
تقنية النمذجة المستخدمة عادةً
لتقدير
النمو الاقتصادي ، حيث قاس
تأثير سياسات الإغلاق في ستة
بلدان انتهت فترة الدراسة في
6 أبريل
مع الاحتفاظ بها.  من المحتمل أن تؤدي أوامر الإغلاق السارية
بعد ذلك
الوقت إلى حدوث تساوي
تم تجنب المزيد من الإصابات بفيروس كورونا وفقًا
للمؤلف الرئيسي
للدراسة ، حيث تضمنت الدراسة بيانات عن التغيرات اليومية
لمعدلات الإصابة
في تعريفات حالة فيروس كورونا
وتوقيت سياسات الإغلاق على نطاق واسع ،
لكن
كان لديها بعض القيود بما في ذلك
البيانات المتاحة
عن العدوى والتدابير في جميع أنحاء
الدولة التي تمت دراستها.
محدود ويمكن للباحثين فقط
اقتراح
تقديرات حول ما يمكن أن
يحدث
للدقيقة الصحية اليوم ، أنا ماندي
نائم على أرض المستشفى بعد أن
تأثرت
قصص الرعب من ريو دي جانيرو
بشدة بـ 19
ولكن فقيرة وتكافح حتى في
صورة واحدة  البرازيل مصدومة
الموتى الذين يرقدون بجانب
العاملين الطبيين في ولاية ريو الحية يموتون أكثر
من أي مكان آخر في البرازيل
30 طبيبًا و 40 ممرضًا أو عاملاً
كما ترونني هنا الممرضة دانييل كوستا
تصف أعراضها في العزلة
قبل أيام من وفاتها صديقتها ليبيا
، رئيسة نقابة الممرضات  مصابة بالفيروس
وتخفي عنها مشاكل دائمة في الرئة
الأسرة أفضل على الرغم من أنها كافية للعودة إلى
العمل ، أسوأ ما تقول هو أنه عندما تكون في حالة من اليأس
لمساعدة شخص وصل حديثًا إلى
المنطقة الحمراء ،
يتعين علينا التوقف عن تحضير جثة
للمشرحة وتركها جانباً عندما ماتت دانييل.
كانت في مستشفى لمدة أربع ساعات خارج
المدينة وكان على
ليبيا أن تقاتل للحصول على سرية 19 في
شهادة وفاتها
في آخر مرة تحدثنا فيها كانت مشعة
تقول
أن حلمها كان أن تعمل مرة أخرى في
خدمة الإسعاف وكان
حلمها يتحقق.
أربع ساعات للتقدم لهذه
الوظائف ، عانقتني
على الرغم من أننا لم نعد قادرين على العناق في ذلك
الوقت
، كانت سعيدة لأنها ستستخدم الزي الرسمي
مرة أخرى
، كان حلمها هو أن النقص في ppe يتم
الشكوى منه على الرغم من
أننا في وحدة العناية المركزة بالمستشفى قيل لنا إنه لا
بأس  يصعب استيعاب عدد من يموتون في ريو على
الرغم من أن البعض يقول إنه لا
يتم الإبلاغ
عن عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص في المستشفى ، هناك 88
سريراً ممتلئاً
وحوالي ستة إلى ثمانية مرضى يموتون
كل يوم
أي حوالي 10 من مرضى وحدة العناية المركزة في اليوم.
هناك حاويات تتسع لـ 75
جثة في الوقت
الذي وصلت فيه الذروة إلى ريو الآن ، يعتقد بعض الخبراء
أن موظفي الرعاية الصحية قد استنفدوا بالفعل
الحداد
والمثقل كاهل نيك بايتون والش سي إن ريو
دي جانيرو البرازيل ،
إنها مخاوف صحية مقلقة للمراهقين الذين
يعانون من أعراض كوفيد 19 تم نقلهم إلى
المستشفى.
تم وضعهم على أجهزة التنفس الصناعي
ولكن تم اختبارهم
سلبيًا لفيروس كورونا بدلاً من ذلك
اكتشف أنهم كانوا مرضى
بسبب التدخين الإلكتروني - الفيبينج -
أعلنت وزارة الصحة في فلوريدا مؤخرًا عن ما يقرب من 120
حالة
من أمراض الرئة المرتبطة بالتبخير الإلكتروني على
مستوى الولاية
، وفي الشهر الماضي تم الإبلاغ عن دخول مراهقين إلى
المستشفى في منطقة أورلاندو مع
كوفيد 19
تبين أن الأعراض تتأثر
بالـ vaping
وفقًا لـ cdc 5.4 مليون
طالب في المدارس المتوسطة والثانوية أبلغوا عن
استخدامهم للسجائر الإلكترونية في عام 2019
بحوالي 1.8 مليون أكثر من العام الذي
سبق أن
قال المدعي العام لولاية فلوريدا إن
الضرر الذي قد يسببه التدخين الإلكتروني للرئتين الشابة
أكثر تدميراً.  عندما يقترن
بـ
covid19 ، يجب على الآباء التحدث إلى
الأطفال حول الكيفية التي قد يعرضهم بها التدخين الإلكتروني - الفيبينج - Vaping
لخطر متزايد
من المعاناة من
الآثار الضارة لفيروس كورونا
الجديد في الدقيقة الصحية الحالية ، فأنا ماندي
غايثر